the german foreign minister heiko mars
has arrived in
israel and will later also visit the
palestinian territories
in the hope of brokering a peace
agreement between the two parties
overnight more rockets were fired from
gaza and israel launched another series
of airstrikes early this morning
despite this a senior hamas official
says he expects
israel and gaza militants to reach a
ceasefire
within quote a day or two for now though
cross-border attacks continue since the
fighting started 10 days ago
more than 200 people have been killed
and many of those victims
are children
a young girl rescued from what was once
her family's home destroyed in an
airstrike
she was buried in the rubble for hours
as her siblings and mother died around
her
calling for help
two days later she's recovering with her
father in hospital
severely traumatized her
i heard the voice of my children from
beneath the rubble
calling me i heard my son's voice
calling
dad dad before he suddenly became silent
he's two and a half years old and my
daughter was calling me
dad dad a few words then
she went silent too
the israeli army has been shelling the
gaza strip
targeting hamas's tunnel systems there
they reported that they took aim at
about 50 targets
but there's no guarantee there won't be
innocent deaths
i have to say we don't rule out anything
we hope we can restore quiet we hope we
can restore it
quickly i want to say that we're doing
that while doing our utmost
to avoid civilian casualties palestinian
president mahmoud abbas
has called for an immediate end to the
fighting
the attacks and destruction in gaza are
israeli
occupation led state terrorism a war
crime
that is punishable by international law
however an end to hostilities in the
middle east still seems a long way off
meanwhile in gaza susie still isn't
talking
she's only just started to eat and drink
again the doctors say they can't get her
the psychological help she needs
because of the fighting if any victims
are innocent here
it's the children
for more on this let's cross straight to
dw correspondent tanya kremer
who is in jerusalem and she should be
joining us quite soon
alice okay uh german uh tanya if you can
hear me
the there she is german foreign minister
haiku mas is traveling to the region
this morning
what kind of diplomatic push can germany
or the eu contribute
to ending this current conflict
well there have been a lot of calls by
eu
member states and other countries to
de-escalate the situation but this
hasn't really translated in the past
days
to any de-escalation on the ground in
israel the visit
by the german foreign minister heike
mars who landed here this morning is
seen as a support
a visit of support and solidarity uh the
german foreign minister heikel master
said before leaving that he
also had a contact in the past days with
his counterparts
in doha amman and cairo also
acknowledging that the main mediation
efforts are of course here
locally originally on the ground so
there's not really the expectation that
a breakthrough
will come during his visit here today he
will be meeting
with israeli officials and politicians
here during the day and will also then
move on to ramallah to possibly meet
with the palestinian president mahmoud
abbas
tanya we understand that there have been
no rocket sirens
since 1am in israel is this possibly a
sign that hostilities are slowly
decreasing
well there hasn't been a rocket fire for
almost seven
eight hours starting from midnight but
just about
over a half an hour ago 40 minutes ago
there were rockets being launched from
gaza mainly into the
near border town areas around the gaza
strip
in israel so of course on the other hand
we've seen also in the report israel has
continued
heavy bombardment on several targets and
areas
in the gaza strip so of course there's a
lot of speculation here now
whether you know this you know longer
periods of quiet might indicate
that there's a willingness at least from
the gaza side to quietening down
but you know nothing is for sure in this
regard
and yet we have heard hamas say that
they expect to reach a ceasefire with
israel within a day or two
is that plausible tanya
well there are a lot of reports on that
at the moment but we have to stress
there were a lot of conflicting reports
about a possible cease-fire in the past
days as well
now there are reports that maybe a
ceasefire could be in place
sometime by friday
so there are reports that egypt as one
of the main mediators is stepping up his
efforts and that details are being
hammered out at the moment but nothing
is confirmed on that that is happening
of course behind the scenes and also the
question is uh
what is the the position of israel
because we heard
prime minister benjamin netanyahu again
stressing that israel
at least publicly he said that wants to
continue its military campaign
so until until yeah when we know when
it's happening
and ending all right dw's tenure kramer
in jerusalem thanks so much